Suge knight gear for finally.
Are you ready?
I am ready.
Let's do it.
Do you getting a lot of heat online from all these?
It's all the flat earth people and the chem trail people.
Those are the people that are mad at you the most.
That's my specialty.
Chem trails and flat earth.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I asked people,
this is hilarious.
I asked people online,
I said a mic west from metal bunk is going to be here.
What would you like me to debunk?
And one of the first ones was chem trails because you cannot debunk it.
It's real.
Dun Dun,
Dun.
I would,
I would say this to anybody who thinks that that has got to be the most
ineffective government program of all time.
Like he asked people what they're doing by spraying things in the sky and the,
the number one thing they'll say is like weather control,
whether controls one,
well,
they don't have any fucking control of the weather because if they did,
they'd make it rain all over Santa Barbara and stop these fires.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's hundreds of millions of dollars worth of damage going on right now.
There's a fire that's bigger than this,
the city of Washington DC,
they think they're making this virus.
They think that that's part of the conspiracy.
Anything that happens is,
oh,
as part of the conspiracy,
what do you think it is?
Like what is,
what is it with conspiracies?
Like what,
why are they so attractive to people?
There's something going on with people,
right?
Yeah.
I think,
and I've been looking into this a lot,
uh,
and you have,
especially since you're a government show,
well,
I'm doing research for the book I'm writing and she's cold escaping the rabbit
hole.
And it's about how people get into the rabbit hole and how people get out of the
rabbit hole.
So the whole thing is about the rabbit hole,
which is something basically people get sucked into.
And I think people do a lot of research into the reasons behind people getting
into conspiracy theories,
like the psychological reasons and the,
uh,
personality reasons and things like that.
But I think most conspiracy theorist or just regular people,
they're just ordinary people who get sucked into something.
And why do you think that is?
I just from talking to them,
they told me like the origin stories,
the origin stories essentially.
And they told me what happened to them when they got into conspiracy theories
and it nearly always starts with them looking at some video.
I now,
now a days,
it starts with them looking at some video and then they just get sucked in and
then they start looking at another video and another video and another video in
Facebook and youtube is feeding them these videos because once you start going
down that road,
you just can't,
you can't change your trajectory.
Right.
It's,
it's hard to train in Youtube what since they instigated this,
uh,
autoplay thing or instituted this autoplay thing or the next video plays
immediately and they're all related.
I think that's definitely been a thing with people.
And also like the suggestions on the right hand side if you're watching one
video on a particular subject.
Yeah,
I was doing some experiments with that are set up like a completely blank
youtube
account and I would just go in there and typing one thing like con trails and of
course we need to look up [inaudible] on Youtube.
Like half the videos you're going to get are going to be Kentrell videos.
Right?
And so if the first video you click on is a chem trail video,
then they just set you down that road.
Well I remember this was in the days,
I think before Youtube,
this is in the days when maybe youtube was around,
but it just wasn't that popular.
I remember me and my friend Eddie,
we're high as fuck and we're uh,
talking to my neighbor and there was some plane that was flying over and we were
wondering why the clouds coming from behind this planes stood so long.
So I asked him,
I just have this neighbor ice,
call him bling bling cause a bling bling was incapable of talking about anything
other than objects.
Like all we talk about that it was nice cars at a new car.
Where'd you get there?
Watch that was blank,
blank.
All bling bling wanted to talk about is like material possessions.
So,
so he,
he know we're parked uh,
in front of his,
I was saying hi to him and then I said,
hey man,
do you remember clouds look sticking around in the sky that long?
And he's like,
ah,
no.
I don't know.
Is that a new truck?
And like
I just remember how ironic it was cause I had told Eddie about blink,
blink,
you know,
that like this is all this guy cares about and wants to talk about.
And then he did that and while we were out there,
but I remember thinking,
man,
how weird would it be if all of a sudden clouds from jet engines started
appearing?
And it just appeared right before our eyes and we had noticed it,
but I wasn't sold.
It didn't make any sense to me because my thought on it was the amount of people
that had to be involved.
You're talking about all these different airplanes get all these people to keep
their mouth shut.
These are their pilots,
right?
So they're not,
they're not making shit tons of money and they live here too.
That's the other thing.
Like if there's actually spraying something in the sky,
they live here too.
Like what are they spraying themselves?
Well,
the theory now is that it's basically the power elite in the country is doing
these chem trails as it kind of latched last ditch attempt to maintain power
before the entire world collapses into chaos.
So they think it's kind of like a desperate situation.
A power grab.
It would not.
Exactly,
it's,
it's the,
the hanging on to have that kind of last hurrah.
I really,
they feel like the end of the world is not like,
you know,
this about to bit this environmental disaster and the chem trails are the only
thing that is holding everything together.
That's the thing that you get if you go to like,
you know,
Jon,
do you engineering watch Dane Whittington Guy?
He,
he's basically a,
an apocalyptic prophet now.
He's basically preaching about how everything is going to end soon and the,
the,
the chem trails,
uh,
the only thing that's stopping it but then also making it worse.
So he's kind of saying like,
you know,
the controls of helping,
but we got to stop them.
Otherwise a little,
they'll make it even worse,
but we're pretty much all going to die either way because a lot of money and
we're going to die.
There's a lot of people that love that,
that that trope
is just like something that gets carted out constantly throughout history
because it's true.
You are going to die.
It's like when are you going to die?
You don't know.
So because you don't know,
you're freaking out.
Like is it going to be a car accident?
Is it going to be a fire,
is going to be an earthquake?
Is it going to be a slow aging death or is it going to be the chem trails dumped
on?
Yeah.
I think that type of thing,
like fear of dying is one of those fundamental things that every human is
hardwired with.
Certain things that are,
they,
that happens in the brain without them thinking about and beer of dying and fear
of other things.
Fear of Lena,
a lot,
fear of wolves or whatever.
Something that's hardwired.
And that's the type of thing that leads to different types of thinking that uh,
you know,
you ended up being a conspiracy theorists in part because your brain is wired
that way.
You had a great quote about chem trails when we did that television show
together.
You said Chem trails are like the training wheels for conspiracy theorists.
Yeah.
Cause they're like they're,
they're right above your head and you just like,
you see them right there for people don't understand why jets produce clouds.
Please explain that.
Cause it's very simple.
It is very simple.
Uh,
jet engines have water,
have water in their exhaust.
You can look at a car on a cold day and you see the exhaust coming out of the
tailpipe.
You'll see like a cloud condensation sometimes and you'll see some water coming
out and when the exact same thing happens with jet engines,
uh,
and when that's exhaust hits,
the colder it condenses,
it freezes,
it makes a cloud.
And con controls are essentially clouds.
They're exactly the same physically as irregular cirrus cloud and it's dependent
upon the amount of moisture in the atmosphere.
And you can actually monitor it online.
NASA actually has a website that will show you a,
and I believe it's set up for pilots,
right?
Is that what the air traffic people?
No,
Sir actually has a contrail forecasting side isn't really for Ios or anything.
It's just part of that contrail research.
Uh,
but yeah,
they have a site where it protect,
well,
controls are going to be,
but you can do it yourself.
You just go look up the relative humidity at a certain altitude.
There's lots of different sites you can go to.
I've got a whole bunch of them listed on metal bunk and just like the clouds
very in the sky,
all the amount of moisture,
various as well,
which is one of the reasons why you will see a jet pass through one area and
you'll see a contrail and then it almost looks like they shut the,
the contrail jets off and then you see it pick up maybe a couple hundred yards
later.
Yeah.
And that's when you say like a cloud,
it's really exactly the same as the cloud.
It can look at any picture of a cloudy day and then just remove all the clouds,
but they're still there as invisible clouds.
Then when the plane comes along,
it's almost like the plane is this the magic pen revealing these invisible
clouds because all,
all the cloud is a,
is a region of the sky where the humidity is above a certain level.
So you know that the humidity is pretty patchy across the sky cause like there's
a cloud here and right next to it there's no clouds where the cloud is.
It's high humidity where the cloud isn't,
it's low humidity.
But if both of those were just lowered like 10%,
then you get no clouds at all.
Then a plane comes along,
he raises the humidity in the cloud area and the non cloud area.
But this area,
because it was a bit higher,
uh,
you get a trail forming and this area getting a trail for me.
So it's exactly the same as invisible clouds.
Yeah.
And for people that are watching it and you're looking up,
you think they're spraying something if you're a conspiracy minded.
And because of a lot of the videos that are out there in particular two that
were recommended to me or what in the hell are they sprang.
Right.
So I got to meet with that guy that made those documentaries and a right away I
knew something was wrong.
Like he's either on Adderall or something.
He's just like real,
real edgy and speed it up.
And just,
just,
uh,
an odd guy,
which is like a lot of people that are conspicuously,
it's conspiratorially minded.
They seem to be like very,
they're nervous and agitated.
And,
and when we went over like why he thinks,
one of the things he was talking about was the soil samples and water samples
and that,
um,
they've detected all this aluminum and barium in water and particularly
aluminum.
And he's showing me all these results that he had,
but even in the very results that he showed me,
it said sludge.
Like he had sent them out for testing.
And I said,
well,
what did you send in his?
He goes,
well,
I sent some water from these,
you know,
ponds.
And I said,
but it says sludge on your testing.
And he said,
no,
but it was water.
I go,
okay,
but the lab said it sludge.
I go,
what is sludge?
She goes,
why don't,
I dunno what sludge is exactly.
I go,
well,
let's look is a combination of water and dirt.
Okay,
so you sent water and dirt.
So do you know that aluminum is one of the most common metals on earth?
And you could basically scoop up a patch of dirt pretty much anywhere and find a
bunch of aluminum in it.
It's really,
really common in trace amounts.
I go,
so you,
what you did is you tested dirt and it tested positive for being dirt.
I mean exactly.
That's exactly what it is.
And the guy was kind of freaking out.
I'm like,
how did you,
how did you not put this together yourself?
Like if you're the guys making this video and you're trying to find a reason why
you could,
you know,
uh,
some facts that you could throw at people.
We could say,
hey look,
the government is definitely spraying things in the sky.
They're spraying them aluminum.
Look,
we found the aluminum and we found that in the water.
It's in your water supply.
It's going to get in your body.
It's going to poison you.
Look,
we found in the water,
how did it,
how the fuck did he not look at it himself is what I was thinking and meet when
me and him were having this conversation.
I realize like you have these people that go down us,
they're not open minded in regards to these subjects.
They go down a very narrow road and that road is,
the government is doing something to me,
I need to find out what it is.
Yeah.
And they're really motivated to actually find evidence.
Yes.
So that the trying to find something and you know,
actually trying to find an alternative explanation isn't really that attractive
to them.
So they find aluminum in the water or in the soil or whatever,
and then they glom on to that as being evidence of geoengineering.
And that's great for them because they can just find loads and loads of samples
of soil.
And that's something that gets repeated online.
That very fact over and over again,
the aluminum that they found in the water,
it's one of light there.
The core tenants is like one of the pillars of the chem trail thing.
There's a,
there's a,
there's like four or five different things.
Like in every conspiracy theory,
there are these core beliefs that,
uh,
the 99% of the people who believe in the theory,
one core belief is that you work for the government.
Yeah.
That is a,
that is a core belief is a retired video game creator.
You could find that out.
Made Video Games,
right.
Tony Hawk.
Yeah.
Made a shit ton of money and decided to uh,
to debunk dorks.
Yeah.
I didn't,
it didn't start out and I wouldn't refer to them as dogs,
but I'm saying they're dorks.
Yeah.
They're dorks.
If they don't believe this is the problem.
You're not a Dork.
If you fall for something,
you're a Dork.
you don't believe the science that shows that it's impossible,
but it's not real.
But if you are spraying aluminum in the sky,
folks,
it would look like aluminum.
You dummy,
it wouldn't look like a cloud.
It wouldn't dissipate.
It would look like a thin missed essentially.
Yeah.
And metals not,
it's heavier than fucking air and vapor.
It's not,
it's not going to just sit up there like that.
It would,
it would be a very different experience.
It would slowly settled to the ground and wouldn't look like a cloud.
And there's no reason to do it.
There's no benefit whatsoever.
There's no scientific evidence ever uncovered ever that there's any benefit for
anybody of spraying aluminum over people.
It's just,
it's just,
it's a waste of Aluma thing.
Even with the whole
geoengineering field is really no solid evidence that it will work and we don't
know what the side effects will be.
We don't know how much we're going to,
we would need to spray and we don't know,
like,
uh,
you know,
if,
when we stopped doing it will look the world bounce back in a terrible way and
it'd be a big disaster.
Well,
that's an interesting thing because one of the reasons why,
um,
con trails are interesting to study is because they actually do have an effect
on the temperature of the earth.
And this is something that we found out after nine 11 when September 11th
happened in 2001 it was the,
the big disaster.
There was a shutdown on all flights in the United States.
And when they did that,
the temperature changed.
Yeah.
Because this is clouds literally do provide like a cover and it is,
it does,
do they act as a,
an insulator or an escalator?
Uh,
they essentially act as an insulator.
They block a radiation incoming radiation during the day and they'd be like
outgoing radiation at night.
But the net is that they actually block more outgoing radiation then they do
incoming radiation.
So if planes didn't fly at night,
then you would,
you would cool the earth down.
You'd have to stop flying quite a bit before nighttime.
So if all the flights in the world,
we were between like 5:00 AM and 5:00 PM local time,
then you could actually call the world down by just not having any flights at
night.
Cause it's the night flights that I have this really big kind of blanketing
effect that stopped the outgoing radiation.
So the night of flights actually heat the world up.
Yes,
they do.
They act like a,
like a blanket.
Hmm.
Uh,
you know how it's,
it's warmer on a well in a cloudy day.
Like he doesn't get as cold at night.
You know,
deserts get really cold at night because there's nothing over them.
They tend to have any,
any cover.
Uh,
it's one,
it's one of the reasons,
but yeah,
they,
the contrary oils will actually a warm the planet because the,
the amount of outgoing radiation they'd lock is just way high.
I just go to the wave lengths and the size of the particles.
Uh,
so that,
that's something to be concerned about.
That's something that people are legitimately monitoring,
um,
where people need to understand is just because you feel like when you look up
in the sky,
you see this criss cross patterns that they're spraying you.
No one's spraying,
you know,
this is just a natural reaction to jet engines and condensation in the
atmosphere and the heat and the moisture of the jet engine.
That's all it is.
They're it.
They are actually talking about a way of using controls for a kind of
geoengineering.
And this is something that people often get confused about.
Cause you,
you see these two words together,
Contreras and Geo Engineering and they think,
oh,
that's chem trails.
But what they're trying to do is use air traffic control and computers and
weather forecasting to make it so the planes don't fly through the contrail
forming areas,
uh,
when they would make Cantrell's at night,
I make it so they do fly through contract or forming areas when it make with the
[inaudible] trials during the day.
So this is our conversation they're having or something that's actually being,
it's not something that they're,
they've actually done,
right.
It's something that they can research fairly easily.
So
we're considering trying to heat up the atmosphere or heat up the earth at
night.
They would just fly over these moisture rich areas and if they weren't,
it would avoid them by,
the goal obviously is to combat climate change,
global warming,
uh,
man,
cool.
The earth down.
So that a relatively cheap way of doing that,
uh,
to a degree is to have these planes,
be controlled by computers.
Uh,
and it could increase his fuel costs,
but the airline by about two or 3%,
because they had to make very deviations sometimes in heights and sometimes in
direction,
but it could actually have a significant effects on the earth's climate if we
had the entire world airline fleets all in this program where they would fly
making controls where they were needed and not making contracts where they were
not needed and how exactly they're monitoring the moisture content of the
atmosphere.
Like what are they using to do that?
Satellites.
Yeah,
it's a combination of things.
Uh,
the edu sounding balloons switch a days.
Weather balloons basically,
which got mistaken for Ufo is quite a lot.
And they use satellites and they use a planes,
uh,
sensing the environment when they're flying through it and they use all these
inputs and it,
and goes into a big computer model,
which basically predicts where,
what the,
uh,
humidity will be at any particular point is basically a big weather forecast for
the upper atmosphere.